thank you guys marcus
when you are in that zone down the
stretch
what is it about those moments that just
make it so easy for you you make it look
easy
uh my teammates believe in me this
culture staff this whole team
organization believe in me
and you know coming in before i hit that
first one to get on that little street
my team is just telling me we need a big
play for me
come out and be you and that's what i
did they kept leaving me open a couple
of my shots were in and out i knew
they're going to start fall just keep
shooting
jason tatum also kept you guys afloat
today you have had a front row seat to
his development
what has surprised you or excited you
most about his evolution in this game
what surprised me excited me the most is
his his development
continues to grow you know we're seeing
spectacular plays
night in night out each and every time
he steps on the floor
and that's all you can ask for him he's
doing his job and helping us get these
dubs and now you're up 2-0
against the defending champs how do you
avoid falling into a place where you
feel just too comfortable
going into game three um for us we gotta
come out and continue to do we did
games one and two even better we know
especially game three
it's gonna be a dog fight like he says
defending champs they've been here
before they know what it takes
and he's gonna take every last one of us
thank you marcus we have a good game to
tune into next
appreciate it guys back to you game
three